someone was going to ask me that was the
thing is that I'm not a politician it's
not my point to make any political
things I just don't believe in the only
thing I can say from a very personal
point of view is that we all know that
there are more violent and more bizarre
crimes bizarre crimes here than any
place in the world except for say a
country at war and terrorist country and
what that says to me only is that our
country is at war in a lot of ways at
war with itself and in an undeclared way
and there is something wrong at the
inner core and that's an obvious
statement but things like this don't
happen everywhere
and
um a brush with death I suppose you know
you do become very realistic about death
but the word of what it means I mean the
idea of shooting means about I don't
know how many calories spent going like
this you know it's a nice little brown
hole black hole I guess I don't know I
see it in movies nice little black hole
that's 20 feet away you don't stab them
you don't touch them and suddenly by
this little tiny thing you've made this
incredible imprint and you've taken a
life and the idea that it takes so
little to cause so much this is pretty
great